hi I'm Mike Considine and I'll read
Gilligan and I'm reek a shower and we're
physics students at st. rose high school
and our question is this universal
expansion have any ties with the
original big bang theory oh hi Mike and
read and read yes the universal
expansion today is the result of the Big
Bang that happened 13.7 billion years
ago yes they're directly tied together
what we think is that the Big Bang
started the expanding universe and then
for the first nine billion years of
history the universe was slowing down
after the Big Bang coasting as the
gravitation pulled back the expansion
but for some reason that we call the
dark energy the universe has now been
accelerating again for the last five
billion years and this is a great
mystery one of the great mysteries of
modern science so we can't tell you why
that is but we hope to tell you more in
a few years or decades as we learn more
about the dark energy